The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: So where were we?
So last time, we were
talking about MS-bar scheme
and renormalons.
And so we talked about
the MS-bar scheme.
We talked about renormalons.
And we said that we could
introduce a mass scheme that
has an arbitrary power log
cutoff, which we called R
to distinguish it from mu, or
lambda or some other cutoff.
And so the idea of
this scheme right
here was perturbing
a way from MS-bar
to get rid of this
renormalon problem
that MS-bar has, but retain all
the nice features of MS-bar.
In particular, we don't really
want to calculate anything new
if we can avoid it.
And that's what this scheme
does because really what it does
is it uses the fact that we
know that the MS-bar scheme has
this renormalon.
So this series here
has a renormalon.
And it just takes that
series over from MS-bar,
puts it in with a
cutoff, which is this R,
and defines a new mass
scheme using that formula.
So this is like a
mass scheme that
has an adjustable cutoff,
which we can take to be
at whatever scale we want.
And in particular,
at HQET, you'd
want to take that R to be
something like a GeV type scale
because that wouldn't
spoil your power counting.
So recall, in HQET,
that this delta m
should be, by power counting,
or order lambda QCD.
So technically, you would take
R somewhat greater than lambda
QCD, but of order lambda QCD.
OK.
So now, we have
this extra cutoff.
So when we have a cutoff, we
have a renormalization group.
And if you think about
the renormalization
group for MS-bar mass, it
would be something like mu
d by d mu of M of mu is equal
to anomalous dimension times M
of mu back again.
This one's a little different.
It's R d by dR of
M of R. And then
there's no M on the
right-hand side.
It's an additive renormalization
to get rid of the renormalon.
And there's a power,
also, of R here.
So it's not just summing logs.
It is summing some logs related
to the running of alpha,
but it's also got this power.
And when you solve this
anomalous dimension
equation, which we
talked about last time,
you get an integral like.
In this t variable and
at leading log order,
it looks like this, difference
of two incomplete gamma
functions.
Because of the
mass dimensions, it
has to be made up
by mass dimensions
on the right-hand side.
Coupling is dimensionless.
The only thing that has
dimensions is lambda QCD.
And that's exactly what pops
out of solving this equation.
The R gets converted to a
lambda QCD by this formula here.
This g of t was just
t at lowest order.
So this is an
all-order form here.
And this is the leading
log solution there.
So if we look at
that leading log
and what is the t0
or the t1, that's
just the same formula
here, but with alpha
at R1 and R0, the
boundary conditions.
We want to run from R0 to R1.
And this formula tells
us how to do that.
And we get a result here
that has the coupling at R0
and the coupling at R1.
OK, so if we look at that
result, it's interesting.
Because if we just had one
of these gamma functions,
these incomplete gamma
functions, then we
would have a renormalon.
And that's where I
stopped last time.
So just looking at this
lambda QCD times gamma
and expanding in a
series of about 0, which
is expanding in the
coupling at infinity,
you get this series, which
has a 2 to the n n factorial.
It's an asymptotic series.
This is a classic
example of a function
that has an asymptotic series,
this incomplete gamma function.
There's some exponential
that combines together
with the lambda QCD to give an
R. So I pulled that out front.
And then we have this
series, which is exactly u
equals 1/2 renormalon.
And the u equals 1/2 had to
do with this power 2 to the n
here, the fact that
it's 2 to the n and not
some other number.
But if we take the
difference here--
and this is what I said in
words last time, but now
I'll write it down in equations.
If we take the difference
there, that actually
doesn't have this renormalon.
So this is the difference
of two series, each of which
is asymptotic.
If we want to
compare those series,
we should expand them in
the same coupling constant.
So let me do that.
So if I take the difference
of those two series using this
formula, but now I re-expand all
these alphas in terms of alphas
at the R1 scale--
so when they're
at the R0 scale, I
re-expand them in terms
of alpha at the R1 scale.
Do some rearranging.
I can write the result
in this form as this.
So the key thing is
that difference there.
And if you think about
what this sum here is,
this is kind of like an
exponential, something
to a power, k factorial.
Except it's limited to n.
So if I really went all the
way up to n equals infinity,
this would be just giving
actually exponential
of R1 over R0.
It would cancel the R0 over R1,
which would then cancel the 1.
You can rearrange the
series a little bit
to make it more obvious
that it's convergent.
Because there is this
n factorial here.
And you might worry,
well, this thing here
has to fall fast enough to
get rid of that n factorial.
So write this thing out,
this 1, as an infinite series
of terms from 0 to infinity
of the same form as this.
And then what you're left
with is the following thing.
All the terms from
0 to n cancel.
And then you're just left
with the terms from n plus 1
to infinity.
And then you can see
that the n factorial
is being tamed by another
factorial growth, which
is always of a greater
power, n plus 1.
OK, so this is a
number less than 1.
And this thing here, beta 0
alpha over 2 pi times the log,
is also something
that's less than 1.
It's exactly the thing
that you sum up when
you're running the coupling.
So this is a convergent series.
And basically the
physics of it is
we had this mass that
didn't have a renormalon,
but it had an arbitrary scale.
And what the renormalization
group allows us to do
is move to another scale.
When we move to another
scale, it better
be that we don't
reintroduce the renormalon.
And the fact that I can write
this as a convergent series
shows very explicitly
that I'm not
having that problem in the
difference between these two.
So it's renormalon free.
And it remains renormalon
free when we change the scale.
And we can sum up
these logarithms
that have to do with
changing the scale.
Why would you care about that?
Well, imagine that you extract
this mass from some B physics.
So you take an r.
that's of order GeV.
And then you say, well,
that's a very precise number.
But how do I use it for,
say, a LHC phenomenology?
Well, if I want to connect
it to LHC phenomenology,
I probably want to convert
to the MS-bar scheme
because LHC is high energy.
Maybe I'm doing Higgs to bb-bar.
Bb-bar-- very energetic, so we
want to use the MS-bar scheme.
But I've got this mass
at a very low scale.
What you would
want to do is you'd
want to use them the
renormalization group,
run it up to the mass scale Mb,
switch schemes from this scheme
where you extracted
the mass to MS-bar.
You'd get a correspondingly
precise value of a MS-bar
because the series between
this mass and the MS-bar mass
is, again, a
renormalon free series.
And then you could take
that mass at the Mb scale,
run it up to, say,
the Higgs scale,
and use it for phenomenology.
So you always want
to be able to go
back and forth between schemes.
And if different schemes have
different scales associated
to them, then you need to
the renormalization group
in order to put them at
the same scale where you
want to do the conversion, OK?
So that's why being
able to sum up
these logarithms without
reintroducing any renormalon
problems is important.
And in general, if you were
to try to do this with MS-bar,
it wouldn't work.
You don't really have
a way of treating
the renormalon in the
MS-bar scheme when
you're talking about physics
below the mass of the particle.
OK, so we can generalize
this little discussion here,
which was a fixed order
leading log discussion.
And I can write down for
you just what would happen
if I were to formally
integrate this integral here
without making any
expansion in alpha S, OK?
So express gamma R of t
as an infinite series.
And it's an infant
series in alpha S.
That means it's an infinite
series in 1 over t.
We had an expression for this
capital G of t last time, which
again was an infinite series.
Just plug in those
infinite series.
Do all the integrals.
They all turned out to be
incomplete gamma functions, OK?
So we can write
down a formula which
is an all-order
generalization of that result
just to see what happens
at higher orders.
So basically, we would
have something like--
if I look back at
what g of t was,
we'd have something like this.
And then all the
rest of the terms
we can expand out in an inverse
Taylor series in 1 over t.
So just there's
two terms in g of t
I want to keep in
the exponential.
And then the rest of them I
can expand out and combine
with these terms.
And that just gives
me some series.
And I can do these integrals.
So writing the integrand out,
we can just establish some
notation for it for that
infinite series of 1 of t's.
And we'll just call
the coefficients Sj.
There is 1 over t.
Yeah.
So this gamma bar
starts as a 1 over t.
So really it should be a
[INAUDIBLE] 1 over t here.
That's where this
1 over t came from.
So then integrate
that, and that gives us
a generalization of this
formula here where we
say that M of R1 minus
M of R0 where we work
at some order in the
resummation, what you would say
is, N to the KLL.
So you have leading
log, next leading log,
next to next leading log.
And when you have K
of them, you say NKLL.
And the solution
of that equation
would be the k-th order lambda
QCD and then this series.
And instead of just the 0-th
incomplete gamma function,
we get a slightly different one.
But it's got the same
kind of structure
where we get the difference
of gamma functions.
And these S's are
just whatever you
get from the
anomalous dimension,
so kind of simple notation.
[INAUDIBLE]
So they're just some
combination of numbers.
And the twiddles here
is just my shorthand
for accounting for
a fact that there's
some beta 0s floating around.
So this is just algebra.
And these b1 hats
and b2 hats were
things that showed up in
the beta function of QCD,
which we also talked
about last time.
So we defined those last time.
The b1 hat and b2 hat were
just combinations of the beta 1
and beta 2 and beta 0.
So these are some numbers
that you can calculate
given the anomalous dimensions.
Given those numbers, you can
plug it into this formula.
And then you have
a generalization
of the previous result.
So whatever order you know
the anomalous dimension to you
can use that solution.
And we'll use it a little later
when I talk about some numbers.
All right, so any
questions so far?
There's a similar
thing for MS-bar mass.
If you were summing
logs of the MS-bar mass,
there's an all-orders
formula you
could write down
and use once you
know the anomalous dimensions.
You could find it in the
particle data book I think.
All right, so just coming back
to this comment about the fact
that the anomalous dimension
is renormalon free--
so the fact that the solution
here was renormalon free,
that the difference here
was renormalon free,
was because there
was no renormalon
on the right-hand side here and
that the anomalous dimension
was renormalon free.
And it was constructed
from something
that had a renormalon,
which is this delta M,
but it was a derivative
of that delta M.
And so the derivative
kills the renormalon.
So this thing is free of the
delta M of order lambda QCD
renormalon because that
renormalon is a constant.
And when you take
the derivative,
you kill the constant.
That's how you can think of it.
If you start writing
out the gamma functions,
then you see that it looks like
you're finding the renormalon.
But then there's
some differences
that show up and cancel it off.
So the way that that
works, it's kind
of like this where
you sort of think
that you have the
renormalon, but then you
realize there's another
term and it cancels it off.
So if we look back at
our formula for delta M,
this had an infinite
series of a's.
This was like a sum over
sum a n's, and some alpha
to the n, some other factors.
And these gammas are
just related to the a's.
But they're not just
related to the a's.
They're also factors of the
beta function that come in.
So just to give you an idea--
so once you know the scheme
conversion to the scheme
and you know the
anomalous dimension
and if you look at this
series and you think about
whether the series for
the anomalous dimension
is convergent or
asymptotic, you can sort of
identify the pattern of how
these coefficients look.
And basically, if
you, for example,
look at the bubble
sum, this a n plus 1
would be something
that has an n factorial
2 beta 0 to the n plus 1--
sorry, to the n growth.
And then this thing here is
n minus 1 factorial to beta 0
to the n minus 1.
And then there's this extra
2n beta 0 that multiplies it.
And you can see that there
is an exact cancellation.
One way of probing
the renormalon
is just to look
at the bubble sum.
And the bubble sum gave us a
particular value of these a's.
And you can see that the bubble
sum renormalon is cancelling
out between the terms here.
So that's just an expression
of what I said over here.
That's the kind of more
definite expression of the fact
that this thing is actually
free of the renormalon.
So I'm going to put
this aside for a minute.
And we'll come back in to
use this formula a little bit
later in today's lecture.
So there's sort of two ways that
you can use this technology.
You can use it as a means
of doing what I said,
of connecting masses
at different scales
and doing phenomenology.
And we'll come back to
that a little bit later.
But you could also use it as
a probe of the renormalon.
So one thing that you might
complain about with the bubble
sum is that it's just some
arbitrarily chosen way
of probing the renormalon.
And maybe there's some
problem where you don't
have light fermions around.
Maybe you only have gluons.
And there could still be a
renormalon in those problems.
So how would you
deal with that if you
didn't have the light
quarks available to make up
this bubble sum?
Or maybe there's
some renormalon that
just so happens you don't
see it with the quarks.
There's no guarantee of that.
So you'd like to have
some other mechanism
for looking for renormalons.
And you can actually use
the renormalization group
to do that, which is
kind of interesting.
So I'll show you how that works.
A nice thing about
this is that it also
makes it clear how
the renormalon relates
to the Landau pole.
So we'll see that as well.
So take our solution
for the RGE,
which we could write in
terms of this integral.
And let's consider what
this integral actually is
doing in the complex t plane.
So the t's are negative,
and so they look like this.
The Landau pole where
the coupling blows up
is where the t goes to 0.
So the Landau pole
is at the origin.
So this is what the
complex t plane looks like.
And what we're doing when
we do the integral is
we're just doing an integral
over that little range
here, right?
So we're far away
from the Landau pole.
And that's why everything
was nicely convergent
and you could connect
one mass to another.
But you could ask, what
happens if I take this t0
and I move it somewhere
else in this picture?
And that's what
we're going to do.
So let's consider the
limit where R0 goes to 0.
If R goes to 0 and you
look back at the formula
that we had that converts
between the MS-bar mass
and this M of R, you'll see
that M of R0 goes to M pole.
Because we had a power of
R times a series of alpha
of R's, which are
just logs of R.
The power always
wins, and so the mass
goes to the pole mass and
that limit that R0 goes to 0.
And if you look
at what T0 is, T0
is related to the
coupling, which
I could write in terms
of a log of lambda QCD.
And T0 is basically in this
limit going to plus infinity.
So what happens is, if I want
to get back to the pole mass
from one of these masses, I
basically have to take this guy
and move out to
infinity, which means
I have to make a choice about
going around that Landau pole.
So basically, you're
taking your RGE
and you're pushing
it into a region
where you're no longer
completely perturbative
and that you're forced to
continue by Landau pole.
Now, you can actually
avoid the Landau pole.
It's true that
the series becomes
non-perturbative in this
region, but you could go way up
here and come back over there.
So you can actually
formally stay
in a region in the
complex plane where
you're perturbation theory
is still applicable.
But you still have to
decide which way you're
going to go around it.
And so that introduces
an ambiguity.
So doing that, say we
go above or something.
And if you plug in this result,
the lowest order leading log
result, you get this integral.
And this integral,
you know, you have
to go around the t equals 0
pole because t1 is negative.
So it turns out that you can
actually take this integral--
and I'm going to leave
this for your problem set--
and write it in the
form of a Borel integral
with an exponential that's
exactly the Borel transform
variable.
So I just change the
variable from t to u.
So I get this integral.
And if you do that, what
you find is that f of u
is proportional to
1 over u minus 1/2.
AUDIENCE: What's the lower
limit of integration?
IAIN STEWART: 0.
Yeah.
OK, so you can actually see that
the RGE and what was the Landau
pole here is effectively,
in this integral here,
becoming this Borel
pole at u equals 1/2.
And that makes a little
more clear the fact
that these poles are related
to the non-perturbative physics
that's in the coupling
and the infrared physics.
So formally, this
actually allows
you to set up a method of
trying to find the renormalon.
You can ask, given some
series, if I sort of construct
this thing, what if I
just had this attitude
that we want to pick that
series to cancel the renormalon?
Now, take the
attitude, what if we
didn't know that that
series had a renormalon?
I could still throw it in,
make a change of variable
to some mass.
If it's a convergent
series, then I'm
just defining some new mass.
And I could go through
this technology.
And it should turn out that, if
the series was OK, so to speak,
then you wouldn't
find this renormalon.
You wouldn't find a pole there.
I won't go through
this in detail
because it is a bit
tricky to derive.
But you can derive what's called
a sum rule for the renormalon,
which is another way of
probing it by basically
taking our all-order solution.
So I took our leading
log solution here, right?
If I did the same thing
with the all-order solution,
I could also take the
Borel transform of that.
And that, if I do that, gives me
this thing called the sum rule.
So it's just manipulating
an infinite series.
And Mathematica can sum
some of them up for you.
So it's just tedious.
And what you find is a formula
for the residue of the Borel
pole.
So let me call
that residue P 1/2.
And the answer is
actually pretty simple.
So these S's were
these coefficients
that were showing
up in our solution
for the all-orders RGE.
P 1/2 is a series
which will tell me
the residue of the pole.
So that means that, if
P 1/2 is not equal to 0,
then you have a u
equals 1/2 pole.
And if 1/2 is equal to 0, then
you have no u equals 1/2 pole.
Now, in practice, you don't
have an all-orders result.
You only know a finite
number of these S's.
So what you actually do
is you look at this series
and try to figure out where
it's converging to, OK?
But actually, even
with the knowledge
that we have of the series, for
example, for the b quark mass,
you can very quickly see that
it has a u equals 1/2 pole.
And you can even do
some error analysis
by varying some things.
And you get some kind of ID
of the theoretical uncertainty
from higher order
terms in the series.
If you just formally, say, take
a series that's convergent,
if I hand you a series
that's convergent,
you can calculate
all these SK's.
And then you can very easily
see that actually there's no u
equals 1/2 pole.
What happens is that all the
terms are cancelling in this
series, and you just get 0.
So it's kind of like the
cancellations I was talking
about where I was cancelling
a poll in the anomalous
dimension, but here it's
happening in this thing if I
have a convergent series.
So this is a way of probing
for renormalons, which
doesn't rely on the bubble sum.
And it basically uses the
perturbative information
that you have available, whether
it's non-abelian or abelian
information.
AUDIENCE: Iain?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when you did,
well, this calculation
here, that capital F, is it the
same result as we found a week
and a half ago or something
that has the renormalon at u
equals 1 and all
that stuff as well?
IAIN STEWART: No, it's
just the u equals 1/2 pole.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what happened
to the [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Right.
So what we've done here--
and actually, I'm just
going to come to this,
but I'll foreshadow.
So what we've done
here is we set up
a construction to remove
the u equals 1/2 pole.
And we did not remove
any higher poles.
We said the u equals 1/2
is the most important.
Let's get rid of that
one from the MS-bar mass.
There would be, in
principle, higher ones.
And higher ones,
basically, we had
something that was proportional
to R. That's for u equals 1/2.
If you wanted to
remove higher ones,
you'd need terms proportional
to R squared, for example, for u
equals 1, et cetera.
So we could have added
more terms to do more,
but we didn't.
We just sort of removed the
problem at u equals 1/2.
And that's why, when
we go through this,
you only see a u
equals 1/2 pole.
AUDIENCE: So if you wanted
to do [INAUDIBLE] analysis
or something, you'd have to
change the result of this--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So the way you
should think about it
is that basically what
you're doing is you're
setting up a scheme change that
perturbatively takes you out
of MS-bar towards
something else.
You remove the u equals 1/2,
and you get rid of that problem.
If you thought you had enough
perturbative accuracy that you
were seeing problems
related to u equals 1,
then you could make
further scheme change
with another series that's
proportional to R squared
to get rid of that one.
AUDIENCE: Wait,
so the Landau pole
would tell you about
all the renormalons?
IAIN STEWART: It would tell you
about these ones, too. yeah,
absolutely.
So you can actually generalize
this for R to the P.
And you can derive a
sum rule for R to the P.
And it's a slightly more
complicated formula here.
And then you'd have
the P over 2 pole.
All right, OK, so the sum rule
is a probe, alternate probe,
for the renormalon.
The nf bubbles are the classic
one that people know about.
And this provides an alternate.
The nice thing about
this is it also
provides a series that you can
look at the convergence, where
the nf bubbles just get a
result. See, nf bubbles are
good for finding
out whether or not
this thing has a renormalon.
If you get some non-0 result,
then you expect that it does.
This way you could actually
calculate the residue
if you wanted to know that
value for some reason.
OK.
Now, that actually might
be useful, for example,
if you wanted to think about
higher renormalon poles
because you might
want to say, well,
let me get rid of the first
one with whatever residue
I can best approximate
for and see if there's
another one underneath.
There's not really enough
perturbative information
that we have about QCD to be
able to do that type of thing.
There's a few cases where
u equals 1/2 is absent,
and then you can do
that kind of thing.
I mean, there's
actually many cases
where u equals 1/2
is absent, and you
can look for u equals 1.
But looking for a
sub-leading renormalon
is something that
nobody's found one.
People sometimes
speculate about them
because maybe the residue of the
first one happens to be small.
This would allow you
to test for that.
In the tau decays
people talk about that.
OK, so let's come back
and actually show you
how you can use this technology
for some phenomenological
stuff.
And I want to do that by
generalizing our discussion
slightly away from masses
towards just a general operator
product expansion.
So everything that we've
said here for masses
can be applied more generally to
an operator product expansion.
So let me show you what I mean.
So let's first consider what
I mean by an operator product
expansion at MS-bar.
So you can think of this like
maybe I'm integrating out
a heavy particle.
And I'm writing a
formula down, and it
has some Wilson coefficients.
It has some operators.
And it's a Taylor
series in this parameter
q, which is the hard
scale, high energy scale.
And I'm basically
just expanding,
if you like, in lambda QCD
over Q. And the operators,
they're set by lambda QCD.
So I'm going to take this
guy to be dimensionless.
This is some
dimensionless observable.
You can always make
it dimensionless
by a suitably choosing,
multiplying by appropriate math
scales.
So then this here will
be a dimensionless Wilson
coefficient.
And it's a Wilson
coefficient in MS-bar.
That's what the bar means.
And so this is an MS-bar
operator, MS-bar matrix element
of some operator.
And it's also dimensionless.
So this guy will be
dimensionless, too.
And finally, this guy will
have dimension equals 1.
Now, at MS-bar, what's
beautiful about MS-bar
is that the series for these
coefficients are very simple.
That's why people like
to compute in MS-bar.
So if you look at what the
series for C bar looks like,
the form of it is as follows.
It's got dependence on mu
over Q and alpha s of mu.
And these guys here are
not an arbitrary function
of mu over Q, but they're
really just some logs.
So this looks like
a series of logs.
So in MS-bar, you're only
seeing these logarithms.
So that's good from a
computational point of view,
but we also know
that generically,
in this MS-bar approach,
you might get sensitivity
to renormalons.
Also, another thing
we like about MS-bar
is that it satisfies all the
symmetries we want to keep.
It doesn't mess them up.
So it's Lorentz and
gauge invariant,
which is always a good thing.
And not only is it simple
for multi-loop computations,
but multi-loop computations are
not even done in other schemes
because they're
just too difficult.
So it really makes multi-loop
computations possible.
And the but, there's
only really this one but,
that it has this
renormalon issue.
So we talked about
renormalon for a mass.
And I just showed you what it
was, and then we explored it.
Here, let me tell you what
the renormalon would be.
So generically, what
the renormalon would be
is the following.
You would have an ambiguity
in the coefficient C0
bar that's of the size lambda
QCD over whatever the scale
Q is.
And you would have the same
ambiguity in this theta 1 bar.
So this theta 1 bar, which
is an MS-bar matrix element
has an ambiguity, which
is of order lambda QCD.
This guy has an ambiguity.
And those ambiguities cancel.
So you're dividing up the
physics again in MS-bar
into short distance physics
and long distance physics.
And the interesting
thing is that there's
a piece of long distance
physics trapped in the C0
that, if you really
wanted, should
be physically in the theta
1 bar and vice versa.
So really what's the
problem with MS-bar
is that there's a
piece of something
that you want in theta
1 bar, but ends up just
being in the C0 bar.
And that's what I mean by this
that there is something here,
which is infrared sensitive.
Correspondingly, there is kind
of an ultraviolet sensitivity
in this theta 1 bar.
And you'd like to
get that rearranged
in an appropriate way.
And that's like this
kind of rearrangement
we were making by changing
schemes for masses.
Except here it's going
to be changing schemes
for Wilson coefficients.
So this thing here is
what we would call a u
equals 1 renormalon.
So what happens
with u equals 1 is
that you make a connection
between the leading order term
and the power suppressed term.
That's what happens
with the delta C0 bar.
So in order to flesh out a
little bit better what I just
said in words, let's
pretend that we
understand what the theory is.
And let's just pretend
it's some integral.
And I'll just show you
what is going on here.
Let's imagine that our
theory is an integral.
Instead of a quantum
field theory,
it's a one-dimensional integral.
And it has two
scales, one which I'll
call lambda QCD, which
is some low scale,
and one which I'll call Q,
which is some high scale.
And I'm using a notation where
the integral could diverge
and I regulate it with a
dimensional regularization type
parameter.
So I'm doing a one
dimensional undergo
but continuing it into
epsilon dimensions
to regulate any divergences.
So what MS-bar does with this
integral is it just says,
well, I'm not going to change
the limits of the integral.
I'm just going to
either expand out this f
or expand out this denominator.
I'll do two different
Taylor series,
and then I'll put them together.
And that's basically how
I'm identifying the terms
in my OPE.
So MS-bar-- so I
sort of associate
there being a high energy
piece where k is of order Q.
And then there's some
low energy piece.
I don't change the limit.
So in the low energy piece,
I keep the full function f.
And then I expand
out the other thing.
And if I drop the
dots in this formula,
I can identify these
integrals as toy models
for the things that are
appearing in my OPE.
So let me write that OPE again.
So here these things
are 1, this example.
This integral here, which
is over high energy scales
k [INAUDIBLE] by Q is this guy.
And this integral here, where
k is of order lambda QCD,
effectively, there's
a 1 over Q, which
is this 1 over Q. That's giving
me the operator, theta 1 bar.
So Wilson coefficient
is the high energy piece
of the original thing.
Matrix element here is
the low energy piece
which is suppressed by
1 over Q, but they both
came from the same
physics in the beginning.
And I just was expanding
it because that's
how I wanted to organize it.
Now, the thing about MS-bar is
that you integrate all the way
down to 0 there.
And you integrate all the
way up to infinity here.
And that's where the
renormalon problems come from.
So this little procedure here
separates the long and short
distance physics for the logs.
It does that correctly.
But for powers, we
effectively rely on the fact
that it's at scale.
This integral goes to 0.
That's what's forced
upon us by the definition
of MS-bar and dimensional
regularization.
And what goes wrong is basically
that physically we're still
integrating over regions of
those integrals which are not
associated to the physics that
should be in those parameters.
So, now, this is a toy
example, but the same thing
is happening in the
quantum field theory
when you think about what
you're doing when you write down
Feynman diagram and you
construct a Wilson coefficient.
It's effectively the same thing
in dimensional regularization.
You're integrating over
all values of momentum.
And this little
kind of toy analogy
is actually apt for what's going
on in a true operator product
expansion.
What would happen if you did
a Wilsonian picture in our toy
model?
Well, then you would cut off
the integrals explicitly.
You'd say, let's introduce
some scale lambda f.
I could still think of it
expanding in the same way.
I don't need the dimensional
regularization anymore.
So I'll set that,
get rid of that.
I think of breaking the integral
into two pieces, the low energy
and high energy pieces.
And in each of those pieces,
I expand the integral
in different ways--
so same type of expansion, I'm
just regulating it differently.
Now, I'm guaranteed
that this is high energy
and this is low energy.
And you can write down
sort of what this is
a proxy for as a Wilsonian OPE.
Mu gets replaced by
the scale lambda f.
Everything gets a
W for Wilsonian.
Again, this is one
with our toy model.
This guy is this guy now.
So it's a very similar
kind of association,
but just the way
that we're treating
the integral is different.
In this way of doing things,
you don't have any problem
with the renormalon.
You just have an
explicit cutoff,
which says there's no
low energy part of this,
and there's no high
energy part of that.
I'm not integrating
all the way down to 0
in the first integral, so
I don't have any problems
with the renormalon.
The renormalon came from
infrared physics that
was happening near k equals 0.
And in this one, there's
no sort of problem
which would come from infinity.
So in some sense, this
is what we'd like to do.
And the but here is that
it causes difficulties
with symmetries.
In particular, it generically
breaks gauge invariance
and Lorentz invariance.
These get broken.
And the calculations
that you would like to do
are just too difficult. I don't
know of anybody that's done--
maybe somebody's done two
loops in the Wilsonian picture,
but nobody's ever done three.
So in some sense, you have
some nice things here.
You have some nice things here.
But they're not the
same nice things.
And you'd like to have something
that does the best of both.
And that's
effectively what we're
doing when we construct
these R schemes.
What we're doing
is we're saying,
well, let's take MS-bar
as a starting point
and try to get rid of
the problem that it has
by perturbing towards
a Wilsonian picture.
So what would an R
scheme OPEC look like?
Start with MS-bar and
make a scheme change.
And make a scheme change
here both to the operators
and make the same scheme
change to the coefficient.
So I'm just really
moving things around.
So let me just
formally write down
what such a scheme
change would look like.
I set up some coefficients dn.
And I do a subtraction on
the operators and an addition
on the coefficients in
the way I've written it.
So that's just a
rearrangement of the physics.
And we've set it up so that the
result of that looks like this.
I took, in this example,
C1 equal to 1 simplicity.
A little more complicated
if I want to keep it,
but we could keep
it if we needed to.
So basically, I've made
a rearrangement to some
equivalent OPE by just
changing the thing,
the definitions here, but I have
now the freedom to pick these
d's.
And what I can do is
I can pick the d's
to have the same renormalon
as the MS-bar scheme.
And, therefore, I can
iteratively, again,
remove the first
problematic term of this
to get a better
defined theta 1 in C0
just like we were
doing for the masses.
So you can remove the u
equals 1, for example.
You can remove the u equals 1
renormalon by choosing the d.
And that's exactly
what the Wilsonian
was trying to do for you.
And that's what it was doing for
you with putting this cutoff.
MS-bar was having problems at 0.
And we're sort of perturbatively
removing those problems,
perturbatively going towards
the Wilsonian picture.
And the nice thing
about this is that we
can maintain the symmetries,
still gauge invariant, still
Lorentz invariant.
And we don't get the full sort
of power of the Wilsonian,
but we get closer to it.
And we can, in some
sense, get as close
as we want, again, by sort
of perturbing this from order
by order.
So what we introduce is
power law dependence in R.
And that power law
dependence, it's
the analog of the
power law dependence
that would be in the
Wilsonian scheme.
So when you have integrals like
this, you would have powers.
There's nothing that
stops you from having
a complicated function
of Q over lambda.
And what we're saying is that
the dominant kind of power law
sensitive terms here
and here are captured
by making this scheme change.
So we decide that we
like MS-bar because we
have calculations that other
people have done hopefully.
If they're three-loop
order, you certainly
hope that someone else spent
two years of their life on it
rather than you.
And you can take and perturb
your results from MS-bar
towards a gauge invariant,
Lorentz invariant
version of the Wilsonian,
of the Wilsonian picture.
So let me give you
one example of that
to show you in practice,
putting in some numbers.
Oh, I'm not quite there yet.
OK, so let me give you a
well-defined scheme which
is analogous to the scheme
that we just talked about,
which was MSR
scheme for the mass.
There's also an MSR
scheme for the OPE.
And again, the attitude is
let's not calculate anything new
that we don't have to.
So we'll reuse the
coefficients of MS-bar.
Those coefficients
had the renormalon.
So if those coefficients
were, we called them
a few minutes ago,
bn mu over Q, we just
reuse these at a
different scale.
So what we do is we
say dn of mu over R
is defined to be
the bn of my over R.
So these guys were the
MS-bar coefficients.
These guys are
whatever we decide
to put into the
series over there.
Just take them to be equal.
That's the MSR scheme.
And then if you look at what
the coefficient is, if we just
write out explicitly
what the coefficient is
by plugging in the
series, you can again
see how it's providing a cutoff.
So this was our
original MS-bar series,
bn of mu over Q. We introduce
a subtraction, which
is suppressed by R over Q
times the same series bn.
And this R is providing
kind of like a power law
cutoff on a problem
that this guy had,
exactly the power law cutoff.
So again, if you look at the
renormalon in this thing,
this combined thing, the
renormalon is independent of R
and Q. So you would just plug
in the bubble series result.
You'd find, actually, that the
R over Q here would cancel out.
And so that these would just
exactly cancel each other.
The u equals 1 [INAUDIBLE] 1.
And again, if I wanted to
probe other renormalons,
I'd have to consider other
powers besides R over Q.
But those actually,
in this OPE, would be
connected to other operators.
So there is other
sub-leading renormalons here,
which could be connected to
1 over Q squared, et cetera,
et cetera.
And in MS-bar, that
generically will happen.
But usually, it
suffices just to worry
about the first one
since many people
in the community that do these
multi-loop calculations don't
even worry about the first one.
Anyway, OK, so you can
again, after you've
got this definition, you
could actually formally write
this as C0 bar [INAUDIBLE] Q, mu
if you want to think about what
it is, minus R over Q,
same Wilson coefficient,
replacing all the
Q's by R. So that's
another way of saying
what the scheme
change is from MS-bar
results to this result.
And this R is acting
like an IR cutoff
to get rid of the bad problem.
And again, we have a
renormalization group.
So R d by dR of this
Wilson coefficient,
it's convenient to think about
that renormalization group
with the log cutoff mu set
equal to the power law cutoff R.
And it's very much
like our masses.
There's some function
with an R in front.
And we could formally
write down solutions to it.
And we can explicitly
plug in results
given how many
terms in the series
we know in the MS-bar series.
So all the anomalous dimensions
of this Wilson coefficient
would be determined
by the MS-bar series,
the original one,
because the scheme
that redefining is set up so
that it uses those [INAUDIBLE]
coefficients.
So what would the RGE look like?
It's the same kind
of structure as what
we have for masses,
some gamma functions.
And you can think
of this as some C0.
If you want kind of to have
a more standard notation,
you would say that this
is some U function.
And this is a bit of abuse
of notation, actually, here
because it's additive,
not multiplicative.
But if you allow me to
put this guy into here,
then I could always
write it this way.
And I'll just do
that for convenience.
So I want to show you one
example of how this plays out
in practice.
And it's related to
our discussion of HQET.
So one thing that
we said about HQET
is that you could calculate
the following quantity.
So HQET makes some
predictions about the B star
and the B. They were connected.
They were in a
symmetry multiplet.
And when you took the
difference of the B star and B
and you took this
combination, it actually
is purely perturbative.
Because there's a
non-perturbative parameter.
But if you treat the
charm quark as heavy,
it's the same for
charm and bottom.
And it cancels out.
So you can actually write down
an MS-bar operator product
expansion, which is
technically defined in HQET.
And what it looks like
is the first thing
is just a ratio of
Wilson coefficients.
So we talked about this.
And we plugged in this
sort of leading log result.
And we saw that it was
working actually pretty well.
And if you were to kind
of look at higher order
terms in that OPE, there would
be some power corrections
to that.
They've got some
traditional names.
The names are not too important.
But this is like the analog
of the 1 over Q term.
This is the 1 over Q term.
This is the leading order term,
which was purely perturbative.
There's no matrix element here.
It's just 1.
This is a higher
dimension operator.
This guy scales like lambda QCD
cubed over lambda QCD squared.
This is just lambda QCD.
So that's like the
lambda QCD over Q term.
And this is the formula
you would write down
if you wanted to make a
prediction for this thing
at higher precision in MS-bar.
So what happens if I think
about this perturbative result
at higher orders?
So people have actually
calculated that coefficient
to three-loop order.
And here's where it looks like.
So at order alpha,
you get minus 0.113.
At order alpha squared,
you get minus 0.078.
And then you get another
minus 0.0755 at alpha cubed.
It doesn't look so
pretty, all right?
So each order that you
calculate is giving you
a correction about the same
size as the previous order.
Well, you might say, of
course, there's logs.
So I should resum the logs.
So let's resum the
logs, so leading log.
And then since I have higher
order anomalous dimensions,
let me put in next leading log.
And actually, I
have one more order.
So let me put that in, too,
[? 908 ?] next leading log.
Uh-oh, all right?
So this is the one that we
actually talked about earlier.
And that one is actually
close to the data.
The leading log result was sort
of close to what the data was.
But when you think about
whether that's actually right
and you calculate the
higher order corrections,
you find that you're moving
away from the data, right?
And again, it's not convergent.
Summing the logs
has not helped you.
And that's because what
we're talking about here
has nothing to do with logs.
It has to do with powers.
It's the renormalon that's
causing this problem, OK?
So we could throw up our hands
and say, oh, it doesn't work.
Or we could try to
do something better.
So let me show you what happens
if we do some of this stuff
that I've been
telling you about.
So this guy has a u
equals 1 renormalon.
You can check that very
easily by doing a bubble sum.
Switch to the MSR scheme.
So we reuse our perturbative
information in MS-bar,
but just organize in a
more intelligent fashion.
So we define a
coefficient as above,
saying that this
problem must have
to do with that renormalon.
And then if we write down
what the OPE looks like,
we have, again, an OPE.
And we've changed matrix
examined definitions as well
as Wilson coefficients
definitions.
So I'm putting everything
in this scale R0.
So that's just rewriting
the OPE in this new scheme.
When we look at this scheme and
we think about what's going on,
we want to choose the
R0 to be of order lambda
QCD or a bit bigger.
And the reason we
want to do that
is to preserve power counting.
So power counting is important
when we're making expansions.
In some sense, it's key.
And if we thought that
the original MS-bar matrix
element was dominated
by the scale lambda QCD,
we better not screw that up when
we make a change of variable.
And so the kind of change
of variable you're making
is you're taking the
original matrix element.
You're subtracting a series with
a proportionality constant R0.
This guy was lambda QCD squared.
And you want this to be not too
far different than lambda QCD,
so that this whole thing
here is lambda QCD cubed just
like this, so that
this thing is still
of order lambda QCD cubed.
So you don't want
to do something
like choose the R0 to be Mb or
something because then you'd
be making a huge change in the
value of this matrix element.
You really want to take the
R0 cutoff to be of order,
say, g of r or something.
So you can use the RGE to sum
up logs from that scale R0
up to the scale of MQ.
So again, we can sum up logs and
have a logarithmically improved
result. But actually the
most important thing here
is getting rid of
the renormalon.
I just wanted to
kind of show you
what the result would look like
with both the RGE improvement,
just sort of using the full
set of tools that we have.
So here's the scales.
You have three physical scales,
b quark mass, charm mass,
lambda QCD.
You have two cutoffs.
You have our R0,
which I just told you
you should pick to be
close to lambda QCD.
And then you can think that
there's these other scales, Mb
and M charm.
If this is some low scale
and that's some high scale,
I'd like to sum logs.
And I can do that by
running up from R0 to R1,
which in this case I'll just
pick between Mb and M charm.
So if you did that,
you'd get some result
that looks like
this, just putting
in some notation for
the resummation here.
And then this guy
is at the low scale.
So now, everybody's happy.
The Wilson coefficients
here can be expanded
in perturbation theory.
We don't think there's
any large logs.
This U sums up any large
logs between the low scales
and the high scales.
And this guy's living at a
scale that he likes to live at.
And there's no renormalon,
no u equals 1 renormalon.
So what does it look like
if I write down this guy?
So first of all, if I look
at this thing order by order,
this is how the
convergence looks.
You get a downward shift
by about the same amount
as before, but the
next shifts are small.
So the series actually
looks like it's
converging to something.
So that's the first three
orders if you use this approach.
And if you use the complete
power of this at the highest
order, you can write down
that you get this 0.860 from
the perturbative part, which
is not too far from the 0.88
or the 0.8517, which I
said was close to the data.
So this actually is pretty good.
You can make some error estimate
for how big this thing is.
And you can make
some error estimate
for the perturbative
uncertainty from higher orders
by varying scales.
And you get a prediction
that looks like that.
So when you want to
estimate uncertainties,
what you typically do with
your cutoffs is you vary them.
You say, well, it
has to be up here,
but I don't have to
take it exactly there.
I could take it up here
or take it a little lower,
move this guy around.
That gives you some idea of
higher order uncertainties
because the dependence
on these scales
cancels out order by order
in perturbation theory.
And so varying it
is a way of getting
an idea of higher
order uncertainties
from perturbation theory.
And that's what I've
done, for example,
for this perturbative term here.
This is varying R1 up and
down by a factor of 2.
And just see kind of what
residual uncertainty you have.
This one's more interesting.
So that one's like mu variation.
And that's because we have
this other cutoff, R0.
But what R0 does is it
connects a leading order term
to a sub-leading power term.
The R0 dependence
cancels between something
that's order 1 in the
power counting, something
that's higher order
in the power counting.
But when I vary R0,
it still cancels
between these two pieces.
Because remember, if you
look at the top of the board,
I've included higher power
terms in my Wilson coefficient.
And so varying the
R0, you can actually
get an idea of how
big this thing is
kind of in a naive
dimensional analysis type way.
And not gives this number here.
So R0 variation
actually allows you
to test for the size of
the power corrections
if you don't know them.
And in this case, it turns out
that the power correction is
kind of small in this scheme.
But it didn't have
to be that small.
It could have been 165, 265.
It happens to be 0.065, OK?
So everything looks
much nicer after we just
get rid of the renormalon.
Someone else did the
three-loop calculation.
You made the prediction,
just true in this case.
OK, so questions?
So the moral of the story
is that, if you really
want to use calculations
that are out there,
you have to think
about the physics.
You can't just calculate, sorry.
So these renormalons, when
you have kind of order
alpha squared or alpha
cubed information,
then you have to worry
about things like this.
And if you didn't, what looked
like was working beautifully
at leading log order
might get spoiled.
You're leading log
might be the best
prediction unless you think
about this that you can make.
Because your just
higher orders, you're
getting sensitive to
this renormalon problem.
And what that means is
generically this is changing
and this is changing.
The power correction
is changing.
And so at each order
that this changes,
I could compensate
by changing this.
But it would have to be a
pretty big change, right?
I changed this guy
by this amount.
And then I have to
compensate by that.
Whoops, now, it even
changes by a larger amount.
Well, compensate by changing
this by order 1 amount.
That's exactly this fact, that
both things have this problem.
Order by order, I can
cancel out the problem,
but then I can never really
assign a number to this.
It's an order dependent number.
Each order in perturbation
theory that I use here,
this number changes.
And that's not
really what you think
of for a physical concept.
This matrix element
should have a meaning
that it shouldn't be
changing by order 1
depending on the perturbative
order that you're working.
In this way of
thinking, this thing
is stable, much
more stable anyway.
And you can assign
a number to it.
That's kind of the moral.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Iain?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That [INAUDIBLE]
looks [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: So the thing
is that the convergence,
it's not about the precision.
It's about the
convergence, right?
So you would be
fine in some sense.
It would not be technically a
problem if this was 0, right?
If this guy was not
much of a shift--
and this was a 15 shift.
This is a 7 shift.
If this guy was small
again, you'd be fine, right?
Because then you'd
say, OK, well,
I extract this thing in the
same order that I include that.
And maybe this thing
gives a plus 0.07,
and this guy is a minus 0.07.
And then I'm close to the data.
And you're happy.
The issue is that you
go to a higher order,
and you get even bigger shift.
That's the real
problem, that you
don't, in the
perturbative part alone,
have any sign of convergence.
That's the issue.
So the fact that this number
is sort of close to that number
is, in some sense,
OK because you
think that this thing should
generically be of that size.
That's what dimensional
analysis would say.
In dimensional
analysis, you might even
say it's a little bigger.
So the real issue is that
you want your predictions
to be stable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I thought that
precision should be higher
than the [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: No.
This, actually, here is
connected to that term.
I'm saying, even if I
leave this term out,
I actually get something
that agrees with the data.
And that's because it turns out
that the power correction here
is of this size.
And I can get an idea of
how big it is by varying
the R0 in this prediction.
And that changes this
number by that amount.
And since this thing is also
changing in exactly a way that
compensates that
R0 dependence, I'm
getting an estimate
for this thing.
That's what I did there.
So if I were to put this thing
in, I'd have a new parameter.
And I could exactly
fit the data, right?
But what I wrote was
a little different.
Yeah.
I kind of went
over that quickly.
All right, so that's
actually it for HQET.
So before we get to
SCET, which is coming up
after spring break,
we're going to talk
about one more topic, which
I'll just basically introduce.
And then we'll stop and
continue on Thursday.
So there's going to be one more
example of an effective field
theory.
And this is going to be an
example of an effective field
theory with what
looks like a problem.
It's got a fine tuning.
So usually, if the whole notion
of effective field theory
is against the idea that there
should be a fine tuning--
because you're making
dimensional analysis
estimates of things.
If there's a fine tuning, that
means your dimensional analysis
failed.
In this example, we'll see that
you can make one fine tuning.
And you can understand what's
going on with that fine tuning
and actually propagate it to
change your power counting,
to change your
power counting such
that it takes into account the
existence of that fine tuning.
It builds the whole effective
theory around the idea
that there was this fine
tuning from original, perhaps,
dimension counting
point of view.
But we can adopt a
different power counting
that actually organizes
the physics in exactly
the right way that we want to.
And in fact, it's going to
be such an easy example where
we can just basically calculate
all the Feynman diagrams very
simply, one line.
So that's what we'll do.
It'll be a very simple example
of an effective theory field.
And we'll prove some things
about quantum mechanics that
would be very difficult if we
weren't using effective field
theory along the way.
So we'll investigate
an effective theory
that has a naively
irrelevant operator that must
be promoted to being relevant.
So by dimensional analysis,
it would be irrelevant.
And one way of thinking
about it is that it just
has such a large anomalous
dimension that it actually
ends up being totally relevant.
And that is actually not a
bad way of thinking about it.
So the example
we'll talk about is
something called
two-nucleon non-relativistic
effective field theory.
So you have two nucleons,
a neutron and a proton,
for example.
It's a bottom-up
effective theory.
We're not going to be thinking
about calculating nucleons
in QCD.
We're going to work
at momenta that
are so small that we actually
integrate out the pion.
So all exchange particles
are integrated out.
So there's nothing to
exchange and really just have
contact type interactions.
So something that you might
think of as like A pion
exchange between
two nucleons gets
represented by some local
operators between the nucleons.
All right, so let me stop there.
And we'll come
back and talk more
about this theory next time.
And we'll see, first, that
these operators of this type
actually can organize
some facts about quantum
mechanics in a very nice way.
And then we'll see how to
think about fine tuning
from this contact
interaction theory
and also how to
think about how we
want to organize the
power counting, what's
MS-bar say, et cetera.
It's kind of a fun theory.